- Good morning, believe nation
today's message is evolve.
Over to you, Usher.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Well, I mean, the thing
is we all have to set goals
for ourselves.
I mean, our plain
destination is to be busy.
And to, you know, adjust to
whatever you're introduced to.
And what I mean by that
is, okay as an entertainer
I started off as a singer.
You know, I grew to become
a dancer and a performer.
After becoming a performer,
then I became an actor.
After becoming an actor,
I became an entrepreneur,
after becoming an entrepreneur
I become an entertainer
on a different level of
introducing other artists.
Then after that I became a mentor.
So I think just to continue
to evolve in a way that is
beneficial for growth
of myself and others.
My likeness to continue to
be remembered throughout
history and associated
with something great.
- Wow.
- For me, there's a
mantra that I do live by
and it is that the
journey of the destination
is really what it's all about.
The pursuit is more important
than the actual destination.
So as long as you are moving,
as long as you are working,
that is the destination.
- Wow.
- The journey.
Really it is simply that, the
journey is the destination.
- I agree.
- As long as you're working, you're good.
- This is, I think, one of
the most important lessons
for entrepreneurs to learn
because the way that you think
something is going to
work out is rarely the way
that it actually works out.
And once you get into it
and you start experimenting
and start testing and start
talking to people and as you
change and grow as a human
being, your business needs to
change alongside of you.
One of the most important
things I think is crucial
to understand is, as an entrepreneur,
you need to be insanely
stubborn and flexible.
You're stubborn around the
why, you're stubborn around
the mission, you're stubborn
around your one word,
you're stubborn around your
values, you're stubborn
around the things that
really really matter.
You're stubborn around the
why, but you're flexible around
the what and the how.
Because that's going to
change a million times as you
build it up.
And so if I look at my
career and what I've done,
what's the why?
The real why for me is
because in my first business
I struggled a lot.
I struggled as an
entrepreneur, I was making $300
a month, I felt like
garbage, I felt like I had no
value to give.
I had the lowest self-confidence
than any point in my life
when I had that first
business as an entrepreneur.
And when I found my way
through and we had some success
and I sold the business I
wanted to make it easier
for entrepreneurs to get through.
I didn't want other people
to struggle as much as
I had to struggle.
That's the why and it's still the why now.
That was when I was 22
and how old am I now?
Almost 37.
15 years of the same why,
the same driving force,
to help entrepreneurs.
The how, the what has changed.
It started off with me being
a speaker and I got invited
to speak at a bunch of different
events around the world
and it was great.
And I still do some.
It transitioned to me doing
a website and having the
most popular website with
famous entrepreneur stories
online.
It transitioned to me
starting a YouTube channel and
making these videos for you guys,
it transitioned to me
writing a book with a major
publishing house, Penguin (mumbles) house.
In my head I'm thinking
about having an entrepreneur
cafe, a place for
entrepreneurs to come together
and work on their business
instead of just having
to go to a regular coffee
shop that's designed for
entrepreneurs and there's
the videos up on the screen
that motivate them and
there's simple business plans
to look through and there's
paintings and quotes that
all are related to helping entrepreneurs.
I see this vision in my head
of having an entrepreneur
coffee shop.
And some point we'll probably
get into the Evan Carmichael
virtual reality put on
your goggles and experience
entrepreneurship.
You know, it's going to change.
And it's great and you need
change as an entrepreneur.
If you're doing the same
thing over and over again
you're gong to get bored.
And too many entrepreneurs
get stuck on one specific
execution of the how and the what.
And you're locked into one
product, locked into one service
and then maybe that even has some success.
Maybe that starts making you some money,
maybe that starts giving
you some impact and some
real benefit.
And then it prevents you
from going out and evolving.
I can't tell you how many
entrepreneurs I've run into
that are bored of their business
and they want to move on.
How are you bored of your business?
They're bored of their
business because they got stuck
on keeping the same how and what.
And losing sight of the why.
Why is always most important,
be stubborn around the why
and you'll continue to evolve.
And have the courage to
introduce new products,
introduce new services, go
in a completely different
direction as long as it's
aligned with your why.
So the question of the day
is I'm curious what your
why is in your business
and what your current what
or how is as well.
Leave it in the comments
below, I'm going to join in the
discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Peter Arca.
Peter, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really
means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up in the morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey believe nation, for those
of you who want a little
bit more inspiration on
evolving and how to do it
as an entrepreneur I'm going
to include a couple extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy.
- We start trying different
things and you try different
cords or different structures of songs,
different beats that you've
never really explored that
path before.
You know, and I think having
always been a writer first,
I'm obsessed with the
syncopation of the way that words
sound when they're said a certain way.
And once I've kind of done
something once I always
want to kind of go to a
different direction and never
repeat myself.
So as a writer I think
that I've always hoped that
my music would constantly
be changing because you
never want to make the same album twice,
the same song twice and my
greatest hope has been that
as I grow my fans will grow
up with me and as I change
and my life changes, my
music will change as well.
So wish me luck there.
- Team Minaj says, "I
love you, but I'm curious,
"why did you change your
rapping style from the come up
"days to today? I love both."
- I don't think I changed my rap style.
I think you guys were
just starting to hear me,
and you didn't hear all of my yet.
I've always been into weird a little bit.
But I think what people
really mean is that they
think that I've changed my persona.
And life is about growth
and change and I don't want
to remain the same for my whole life.
I want to be able to change
and I respect the people who
loved, you know, '07 Nicki
and definitely going to
give you some stuff on Pink Friday.
Like, I'm not forgetting
anybody, but I also have to be
true to me.
And the truth is, I started
seeing different things,
I started going different
places, I started eating
different things.
I can't, it would be
fraudulent to rap the same way
and look the same way and
act the same way because
I am not the same, period.
I don't know how to--
- Well everyone has their
different belief systems.
I think everyone has their
different opinions of
those types of things
that you talked about.
Certainly, as an athlete,
I care very much what I put
into my body.
I think that, I'm 38 years
old, I'm not 22 anymore.
- You look good.
- You're very sweet, thank
you, but all those things
are important.
And all the little things
add up to be big things.
So when I'm trying to
accomplish things professionally
that in a lot of ways I'm
in uncharted territory
so I've got to do things
differently and I've got to
evolve over time.
I've got things that may
have worked in the past
maybe don't work as you move forward.
So the lessons that I've
learned through my own
trial and error, I think I'm
at that point in my career
where I'm very efficient
with what I'm doing.
So I try to eat healthy, I
try to get the right amount
of rest, I try to do the
right types of exercise
so I can be on the field and
be available for my team.
I try to be as productive
this time in my career
as I was earlier.